قد ينتهي قريباً ترشح بنيامين نتنياهو
كرئيس وزراء إسرائيلي لأطول مدة خدمة.
حكومة
بدون نتنياهو
، يُعتقد على نطاق واسع أنه كجزء من
اتفاق الائتلاف هذا ، سيعمل نفتالي بينيت
كرئيس للوزراء
أولاً يليه يار لابيد كجزء من
اتفاقية قيادة متناوبة
الآن ، سيتكون هذا الائتلاف من مجموعة
واسعة من الأحزاب السياسية التي
تتراوح من اليسار.  - حزب العمال الجناح من
خلال حزب الوسط
وحزب yamina بزعامة نفتالي بينيت
على اليمين ، قد يحتاج أيضًا إلى
دعم خارجي من
حزب إسلامي صغير يسمى رام ، لكن نفتالي
بينيت قال في خطاب متلفز
مساء الأحد إنه مستعد للجلوس
مع الأحزاب  على الطيف الأيديولوجي
الآخر مثله من أجل منع
إسرائيل من اجتياز جولة خامسة
من الانتخابات
أعلن اليوم أنني أعتزم
العمل بكل قوتي لتشكيل
حكومة وحدة وطنية
مع صديقي يايا لابيد حتى
نتمكن من إنقاذ البلاد من
هذا التعصب وإن شاء الله معًا وسنعيد إسرائيل
إلى المسار الصحيح.
خطابه المتلفز مساء الأحد
قال فيه أن بينيت يخدع
الجمهور وأن هذه الحكومة الائتلافية الجديدة
ستكون يسارية
وستشكل تهديدا لأمن إسرائيل.
هذا من رجل كان
يساهم بالفعل في الكراهية والانقسام
، رجل كان يرتكب
خداع القرن ،
ما يحدث بعد ذلك يجب على جميع هذه
الأحزاب المختلفة التوقيع رسميًا على
اتفاقيات الائتلاف الخاصة بهم قبل أن يتم
تقديمها إلى الرئيس الإسرائيلي
ثم البرلمان الإسرائيلي المعروف  حيث يتعين على
الكنيست أيضًا التصويت للموافقة على
الحكومة الجديدة
مما يعني أن إسرائيل قد تكون على بعد أيام
قليلة.  قبل أن يؤدي أداء اليمين الدستورية في حكومة جديدة
وأداء اليمين
لرئيس وزراء محتمل ويمكن أن
تتغير الأمور بسرعة في السياسة الإسرائيلية ، فقد يؤدي
مجرد انشقاق اثنين أو نحو ذلك من هذا
الائتلاف إلى انهيار الصفقة برمتها
هداس جولد سي إن إن القدس